even with the interest rate hikes people
are still looking for homes but the
number of black homeowners remains low
in fact the home ownership Gap is wider
than it was prior to the Civil Rights
Movement Candace Charles shares some new
data as well as some solutions
nice what do you guys think zorray and
Leo Jones have been looking for a home
for a few years now I'm actually going
to be like one of the first home buyers
in my family home ownership is often a
gateway to generational wealth but
according to Sade Bushra with today's
homeowner magazine and website US Census
Data shows for black families a home has
been more of an unlikely reality than an
American Dream the black white home
ownership Gap was the same in 2020 as it
was in 1970 according to the U.S
Department of Treasury there has been a
uh a certain let's let's say benign
neglect of this cause butcher also cites
blacks have faced barriers to home
ownership because of discriminatory
practices by mortgage lenders and real
estate agents I thought things were
getting better until I looked at the
data Butcher and his team analyzed more
than 10 years of home ownership data and
says Nationwide there's about a 30
percent Gap black homeowners are
generally less resilient we can say two
economic shocks like the Great Recession
in once the housing crisis hit Banks
were also becoming stricter last year
Wells Fargo was sued for discriminating
against black homeowners a larger part
of justice department settlements Are
banks creating a minority unit Valerie
Esperanza Chavez is a part of the Wells
Fargo's home lending agent and Hispanic
segments we're working across
stakeholders policy makers non-profit
organizations and we as a lending
Community are making sure that we're
driving the solutions it recently
started a special purpose credit program
for its current borrowers we all should
make our best effort to turn those
numbers around because now there there
are opportunities Tony swaggery is the
Joneses realtor and says the community
often faces a shortage of information
and guidance when buying a home he and
Esperanza Chavez says budgeting and
cleaning up your credit is a great start
Candace Charles there with that report
Wells Fargo holding a virtual education
opportunity on Wednesday can find the
link to sign up and all this information
on our website at 8newsnow.com